Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Guten Morgen und Hallo zur Jazzlaun, schall und herzlich willkommen bei meinem Studio heute, Stefan Tietzel. Es ist genau acht Uhr, gute Autofahrt. Es ist tatsächlich sehr, sehr früh. Es ist wirklich sehr, sehr früh und ich bin ein bisschen traurig, dass das Intro schon geendet hat. Als ich am Anfang die Jazz-Klänge vernahm, war meine erste Frage, wie lange dauert das? Ja, ich glaube, wenn ich... Wie lange geht das hier? Das ist eine Sitzung. Wenn ich bei der Pantomime den Begriff Jazz machen würde, würde ich so auf die Uhr gucken. Würde ich auf die Uhr gucken. So dieses, Leute, das geht schon seit acht Minuten. Nee, ich würde sechzehn Minuten lang angespannt und auch angeregt zuhören. Tatsächlich habe ich ein bisschen eine Jazzwoche hinter mir. Ich habe mich ein bisschen reingehört. Schön Miles Davis, Bill Evans. Ach so, ich sagte, so eine jazzige Woche. Nee, nee, nee. So eine Boge-Jazz. Nee, so war sie sehr konservativ. Also wirklich von, ichre jeden Tag von neun bis zehn Jazz, ganz Stichuhradend, genau. So einen stundenplanartigen Tag, oder nicht? Ja, und es ist interessant, viele Sachen, die man schon so angehört hat. Ich check nicht ganz, wie ein Jazz-Song funktioniert, weil es ist ja viel improvisiert, oder nicht? Viel improvisiert. Viel auch, ob die anderen hören. Aber improvisieren wir das dann immer gleich? Oder ist es dann, ich verstehe es nicht ganz, es ist dann immer viel und dann so, nee, C, C-Dur, C-Dur und ja, ach so, sorry. Und das halt wirklich über Stunden hinweg, das kannst du ja echt nicht ertragen. Das kannst du nicht ertragen. Nee, es gibt, glaube ich, ganz klassische Regeln, wie beim Impro. Es ist die Frage, ist Impro, Comedy und Jazz nicht ein und dasselbe, nur ohne die Comedy? Ich glaube, es ist fast das gleiche, ohne dass du ein Instrument lernen kannst. Ach so. Klar, du kannst natürlich auch ... Auch hier geht die oberste Regel, ja und. Tonart annehmen und weitermachen, nicht, nee, ich bin in S-Dur, keine Ahnung, wo ihr seid, Tschüssikowski, und dann gibt es da so verschiedene Riffs, die die spielen. The Lick zum Beispiel. Das ist ja dieses Klischee-Riff, wenn sich Jazzmusiker lustig machen. Auch über die Hochzeitsgesellschaft, wo sie gerade spielen irgendwie. Dann machen sie andauernd, jagen sie sich halt The Lick um die Ohren. Ah, okay. Und dann macht der Saxophonist. Guck mal, was für ein Vollidiot. Guck mal, was für ein Fetzer in der ersten Reihe. Hey, ich kann euch hören. Warum sitzt ihr ... Das Prinzip erste Reihe gibt es bei Jazz auch, glaube ich, gar nicht. Ich glaube, das ist so einfach meilenweit. Wir waren ja in New York in ein paar Jazzbars. In ein paar. Als wäre das unser Thing gewesen. Einmal muss ich euch zwingen.
Wir waren in genau so vielen, dass man im Erzählen des Urlaubs den Plural verwenden kann. Man kann sagen, wir waren in Jazzbars. Zwei.
Niemand muss wissen, dass es nur zwei waren. Wir waren in mehreren verschiedenen Jazzbars. Das kann man dann sagen.
Nicht so schlecht, oder? Man muss immer so viel Urlaub machen, man muss immer an die Erzählung danach denken.
Natürlich. Man muss immer daran denken, wie würde ich für diesen Urlaub erzählen. In Jazz-Bars klingt wesentlich cooler. Nee, das stimmt, wir waren aber nur in zwei, weil die Eintrittskarte für zwei Jazz-Bars waren. Das stimmt. Wir waren in beiden exakt zwei Minuten, glaube ich, weil wir danach zu irgendeinem Broadway-Stück mussten. Und Tarkan sehr müde geworden ist von Jazz. Das merkt man ja erst, wenn man mit jemandem in der Jazz-Bar wird. Jazz wirkt ja auf jeden Menschen anders, ein bisschen wie Alkohol. Manche werden aggressiv, manche werden blue, ja, und Tarkan wurde einfach sehr müde und dann mussten wir ihn nach Hause bringen und ins Bett legen. Wir mussten ihn auf dem Kindersitz hinein, hinten ist schon eingeschlafen, auf der Rückfahrt, und dann haben wir ins Bett Bächchen gelegt. Dann sind wir nochmal los. Was ich aber faszinierend fand, ist, dass da auf der Bühne, über der Bühne, also die drei Musiker standen, es war so klassischer Jazz-Quartett, also Kontrabass, Schlagzeug, Klavier, und über der Bühne war so ein Spiegel angebracht, sodass die Zuschauer auf das Set des Drummers schauen konnten. Weil so als Drummer hast du ja das Problem, man sieht nicht genau, was du machst, also gerade was der da füsselt und so, sieht man ja nicht. Und deswegen hat der extra gesagt, nee, ich will, dass die Leute mich nicht nur hören, ich will auch was fürs Auge geben. Und dann haben die so einen Spiegel angebracht, wo man dann Spiegel verkehrt. In seinen Schritt, genau in seine Erektion gucken konnte. Es war total merkwürdig, weil es war natürlich interessant anzusehen, aber ich denke mir immer so, ich kann nicht anders, als bei solchen Sachen drüber nachzudenken, wie lässt man sowas natürlich ins Gespräch fließen? Du bist ein mittelmässig erfolgreiches Jazz-Trio und irgendwann sagst du, wir haben echt alles super, Kontrabass wunderbar, ein bisschen groß, aber super. Wie wäre es denn, wenn wir noch so einen Spiegel über mir anbringen würden? Ach, du meinst Spiegel über uns? Nee, über mir speziell meine ich. Damit man mal genau in den Schritt gucken kann. Aber das Klavier sieht man ja auch nicht. Du kannst ja auch einen Spiegel haben. Das ist ja dann dein Entschlag. Aber ich hätte halt die Idee mit dem Spiegel. Oder kann man nicht deinen Spiegel in meinem Spiegel spiegeln? Ja. Wenn jemand reißt das Licht auch durch die Spiegel so lange, dass das Licht auch irgendwann sagt, nein, ich bin raus. Jetzt sieht es sich konstant selbst falsch rum.
Falsch rum und so
verzogen, wie den Spiegel im Freizeitpark,
mit so einem grossen Gesicht,
mit so einem dicken Backen. Deswegen sagt man ja auch, Jazz
macht fett. Einfach nur durch die
Verzerrung. Also tatsächlich,
wir haben mal in so einer
Sexhöhle gedreht.
Also man weiß nicht, ob es eine Sexhöhle war. Ich glaube, den, Gute Arbeit Alexa-Sketch, dieses Alexa bekommt ein eigenes Bewusstsein. Und da haben wir irgendwo gedreht, was glaube ich früher in den 80er Jahren in der Kölner Hochzeit so als Sexhöhle gedient hat. Die meisten Kommentare waren auch, der Boden ist dreckig. Ja, das stimmt. Also das ist so ein sehr weider Kommentarspalt.
Viele verschiedene Flecken. Und der hat auch ein Wasserbett, das erste Mal im Leben auf einem Wasserbett und über dem Wasserbett ein Spiegel. Und dir ist es schon schlecht auf einem Wasserbett. Und dann schaust du dich selber noch an und du wobbelst so hin und her. Wobbelst. Ja, du wobbelst. Ganz merkwürdig, auch so ein Ding. Wann entschließt man sich ein Spiegel? Also man muss ja den Spiegel, Der Spiegel ist ja grösser als die Tür. Das heißt, eigentlich musst du ja das Haus um diesen Spiegel bauen, weil anders kannst du den Spiegel nicht einfach zuklappen. Es sind wie so alte Bäume oder so Relikte aus alten Zeiten, wo man dann endlich entschließt, darum baue ich jetzt mein Haus. Und dann müsste der Architekt natürlich damit arbeiten, was man hat. Aber das ist eine gute Frage.
Oder wird ja da drin gegossen,
wie entstehen Spiegel? Da sollten wir vielleicht mal anfragen.
Ganz schwierige Frage, glaube ich.
Ich glaube, das ist eine streng gehütetete Geheimnis,
das weiß niemand.
Ja, das ist, glaube ich, echt nicht so trivial.
Spielt Glas
überhaupt eine Rolle beim Spiegel?
Ich glaube schon. Ich glaube, Glas spielt eine enorme Rolle
beim Spiegel. Ja, weil man das, also, ich sage mal, den Kaputt, Spiegel kaputt hat, erinnere mich an Glas. Ja, aber es gibt ja auch so einen Spiegel, der nur der sozusagen Einbahnstrasse ist, durch den man durch die eine Seite durchgucken kann und von der anderen Seite so ein Spiegel, so Verhörspiegel. Meinst du auch Verhörräumen? Ja, genau. Aber die geht es auch nur da dann. Das wäre mega, in jedem Haus so einen Spiegel zu haben eigentlich. Und dann aber auch, ganz kurz, Spiegel nicht einfach nur Alufolie mit einer Glasscheibe drauf. Nur mal so, ich will... Stefan, du hast letzte Woche schon ein paar Zünder rausgehauen, die die Community aufgewirbelt haben. Ich will jetzt nicht entmystifizieren, aber ich glaube, es ist einfach nur Alufolie mit einer Scheibe. Ist es nicht einfach Wasser? Weil im Wasser spiegelt man sich ja auch. Hartes Wasser. Sehr viel Kalk. Vertikales Wasser einfach. Also hat man es nicht hingekriegt durch durch Molekularstrukturen. Wasser halt, Wasser ist ja flach, also so H2O, neben H2O so ausgebreitet. Du meinst horizontal eher. Ja genau, horizontal. Kriegt man es nicht hin, dass durch die molekulale Umstrukturierung molekulale? Molekulale Umstrukturierung zu sagen Chemiker. Ich verstehe auch nicht, warum so Morning-Show-Leute die ganze Zeit so ein bisschen so sprechen, warum die so fit sind. Ja, das stimmt, es ist wirklich extrem früh, weil Stefan heute Abend nicht kann, weil er zum Essen eingeladen ist, der feine Herr. Ja. Und er kann nicht mal sagen, Entschuldigung, ich muss ganz kurz weg, um dann einfach kurz einen Podcast mit mir
aufzunehmen, um dann, Entschuldigung, es hat ein bisschen länger
gedauert. Das geht nicht. Faustregel, je teurer
das Restaurant, desto leiser musst du sprechen.
Entschuldigung, ich muss ganz kurz weg.
Ich meine nur so
Basswellen.
Was?
Ja, es stimmt schon.
Aber ich glaube, heute Abend, das ist so ein teures
Restaurant, da kann ich nicht einfach sagen, ich muss ganz kurz weg.
Wie lange muss man sich vom Tisch entfernen, bis Leute fragen, wenn man wiederkommt, wo warst du? Nee, um dem Klo. 40 Minuten lang? Ja, wenn du kurz auf dem Klo. Ach so, okay, dann ist es auch noch ein Wunderwoll. Wo wir gerade bei Schlagzeugern waren, ich kam jetzt erst da zwischen, lustig. Und zwar, ich fand die Frage nämlich nicht schlecht. Wie lässt man ins Gespräch einfließen, dass man einen Spiegel über dem Schlagzeug will? Weil unser Schlagzeuger damals, wir hatten als Band das Problem, es wurde immer mal wieder zugesteckt, dass unser Schlagzeuger zu laut ist. Es wurde immer mal wieder so ein Problem. Beispiel, kleine also so Vereinszentren, so Jugendfreizeitzentren zum Beispiel, dann hast du halt da keine große Bühne und keinen Abstand zum Publikum, ob es auch kleine Räume nur. Das heißt, und im Idealfall hast du es irgendwann als Band geschafft, dass du sozusagen so eine Frontline hast, dass du quasi eine Bühne hast und dann hast du eine grosse PA, eine grosse Verstärkeranlage und all deine Instrumente werden abgemischt darüber.
Und mein Bassverstärker, wenn ich Bass gespielt habe,
also meine Bass-Lautsprecherbox oder die Gitarrenbox,
sind eigentlich nur für den Bühnensound da,
damit wir uns auf der Bühne gut hören.
Und dann kommen vorne die PA, das sind die grossen und grossen Boxen,
die abgemischt dann die ganze Band dem Publikum zeigen. Das wäre optimal. Das machen die professionellen Bands. Bei uns war das damals nicht möglich, weil unser Raum so klein war, dass der Bühnensound gleichzeitig der Raumsound ist. Man muss sich entscheiden, wollen wir boxen oder Zuschauer? Beides geht nicht. Beides passt sich in diesen Raum. Problem. Da haben viele Krisensitzungen als Band. Da muss man uns irgendwann entscheiden. Haben wir zum Publikum entschieden? Können wir nicht Kopfhörer verteilen? Das ist einfach jeder. Eigentlich ist das das Beste. Kopfhörer. Ja, das wäre eigentlich das Beste. Ging nicht, tatsächlich, weil kein Geld aber. Zu wenig Kabel. Zu wenig. Jeder Kopfhörer ein Kabel. Ich glaube, es gibt auf der Welt auch nur drei Augs-Kabel. Ja, stimmt. Das ist, glaube ich, echt ein Problem. So ein Augs-Verteil, dann wird es wahnsinnig leise. Ja. Dann wird der Sound so gesplittet. Man muss sich entscheiden. Viele Kabel laut oder leise, also, und dann mussten wir ihm irgendwann mal mitteilen, dass er zu laut ist. Ja. Und das ist dann ein bisschen schwierig. Ja, ja. Im Schlagzeug zu sagen, dass er zu laut ist. Und dann war mein Vorschlag,
weil ich es im Fernsehen mal gesehen hatte,
so einen Plexiglas-Kasten um ihn herumzubauen.
Während der Performance langsam, Stück für Stück
aufbauen. Langsam, hups, wo er sich
am wenigsten wehren kann. Weil er muss ja
spielen, trommeln. Aber hattet ihr nicht auch
kurz die Idee, dass einfach alle anderen lauter
sind? Natürlich war das die Idee.
Problem, dann werden alle lauter und es entsteht so eine Aufwärtsspirale aus Lärm. Dann wird er alle anderen lauter sind? Natürlich war das die Idee. Problem, dann werden alle
lauter und es entsteht so eine Aufwärtsspirale
aus Lärm. Dann wird er auch wieder lauter.
Wo dann auch die westfälische Rundschau dann irgendwann
schreibt, das war zu laut.
Einfach. So sind ja auch klassische
Orchester entstanden, dass immer mehr
Geiger dazugekommen sind und die
Trompeter gesagt haben, ja Leute, dann brauchen wir auch mehr Trompeter.
Du meinst, das war wie so ein Gangfight.
Das war so ein Hochwiss.
So ein Dimm, Dimm, Dimm, Dimm, Dimm, Dimm, ja Leute, dann brauchen wir auch mehr Trompeter. Du meinst, das war wie so eine Gangfight. Ja. So ein Dum, Dum, Dum, Dum, Dum, Dum, Dum, Dum, Dum, und dann ich hab ...
Komm schon!
Mehr Trompeter!
Jeden Tag sind so zehn Geiger da und der Kontraber sitzt halt auch, Leute ...
Ja, es ist so ein musikalisches Aufrüsten einfach, dass so einfach beide Parteien sagen,
Leute, komm her!
Übrigens, Westhead Story bald in Köln.
Ich weiß, rat mal, wer schon Tickets hat.
Nein, aber ist das dann auf Deutsch?
Ja, ich glaube leider ja.
Aber wobei die Songs, da weiß ich nicht. Heute Nacht, heute Nacht. N-N-N-Amerika, n-n-n-n-n-Amerika, n-n-n-n-n-Amerika, n-n-n-n-n-Amerika.
Ganz ehrlich, ich fühle die deutsche Version ähnlich gut.
Es stimmt schon. N-N-N-N-Amerika, N-N-N-N-Amerika. Ganz ehrlich, ich fühle die deutsche Version ähnlich gut.
Es stimmt schon.
Naja, also ich weiß nicht genau, ich habe auch schon Miss Saigon verpasst, wo ich auch schon sehr viel Bock drauf hatte, weil wir beide von Le Miserable, Frau Saigon, Fräulein Sögner haben wir auch schon verpasst. Weil, ja, also ich fand damals schon De Miserable, aber vom gleichen Komponisten ja auch,
Claude Michel Schönberg oder so heisst der, ich, wo Vorname und Nachname unterschiedliche Länder sagen. Von dem war das jedenfalls und von dem ist auch Miss Saigon, deswegen, das haben wir leider verpasst. Aber wir sind nächstes Jahr, dieses Jahr ja vielleicht wieder in New York. Das stimmt, das heißt vielleicht können wir endlich mal Hamilton sehen. Ja, wahrscheinlich nicht, oder? Oder gibt es ja mittlerweile Tickets? Ich kann das, glaube ich nicht. Oder warum nachher nicht einfach daneben noch ein Theater, wo es auch immer gespielt wird? Oder eine größere Halle? Ja, ich meine, Leute, es gibt Möglichkeiten. Langsess-Arena, hallo? Diese künstliche Verknappung nervt. Das ist lächerlich. Die ist ein großes Problem. Na, so Hologramme kann man ja machen. Ist ja jetzt ordentlich Schärft aufgetreten oder so, dann kannst du ja irgendwie in ganz vielen Locations in der ganzen Welt halt einfach die Hologramme zeigen. Wo ist das aufgetaucht? Nee, wie heißt der, der erschossene Tupac? Ja. Diggi? Der ist jetzt mit dem Hologramm aufgetaucht? Diggi ist irgendwo Der ist ja in Chile mit dem Hologramm aufgetaucht. Der hat ein Konzert gegeben, nur als Hologramm. Jetzt wieder? Weil er sich als Hologramm Weil er hätte es so gewollt. Och Gott. Und dann alle sagen, wirklich? Und einer sagt ja. Irgendwann müssen wir als Gesellschaft auch mal sagen, wenn jemand es so gewollt hätte. Hätte er es gemacht. Er hätte es gemacht, erstens, und zweitens ist er jetzt tot, und wer sind wir jetzt noch seinen Wunsch erfüllen zu müssen? Ja, stimmt schon. Wir leben noch. Das ist ein guter Punkt. Das wäre mein Punkt. Hättest du vielleicht nicht bei der Beerdigung mehrmals erwähnen müssen. Ich habe nicht verstanden, warum unser bester Freund, der mit dem dreiischen Autounfall umgekommen ist, noch unbedingt den Ententanz aufführen wollte. Als Hologramm. Weißt du, wie aufwendig das ist? Ja, aber du hättest ja der Mutter nicht mehrfachfach Wir leben, wir leben, ja, wir sind die Lebenden, uns gehört die Welt ins Gesicht schreien sollen. Wir sind die Lebenden, er ist mausetot. Ja, das ist klar, deswegen sind wir alle hier. Ob das Wort mausetot immer bei einer Beerdigung gefallen ist? Mausetot? Ja, das ist ein guter Punkt eigentlich. Wenn ich tippen müsste, würde ich sagen, nee. Ich bin bin dafür dass man immer mal also als mensch musste man die meisten firsts hinbekommen ich finde du hast gelebt wenn du sagen wir mal in deinem leben fünfzig firsts gemacht hast okay also was schon gute frage noch nicht so viele glaube ich also während einer band aufbährend des bandauftritts ein plexiglas kasten aufzubauen und Schrauben zu suchen, ganz kurz, niemand bewegt sich, mir ist der Sechskandler hingefallen, ist glaube ich schon First. Erster minderjähriger Grimme-Preisträger? Vielleicht? Ja, kann sein. Kann schon sein. Ich habe nie einen selber bekommen, immer nur diese Teampreise. Das wäre nochmal ein Ziel. Ich glaube auch das Wort abgekratzt relativ selten bei Beerdigungen. Abgemurks. Hinüber glaube ich, gibt es auch relativ selten. Aber das wäre tatsächlich, also falls, man muss aufpassen mit solchen Gäckigen, ich will, dass nach meinem Tod X passiert, weil am Ende passiert ist. Also wenn ich jetzt Gäckig sagen würde, ich hätte gern, dass bei meiner Beerdigung das Wort verstorben durchgehend ersetzt wird durch Mausetod, ist abgekratzt, oder hat es nicht geschafft, hat einen Löffel abgegeben, die Ohren angelegt, dann könnten es Leute tatsächlich ernst nehmen, deswegen muss man mit sowas echt aufpassen. Die sagen als Scherz, ich hätte gerne, dass bei meiner Beerdigung der Pfarrer Mario Kart spielt und es mindestens bis zum achten Level schafft. Am Ende passiert das dann, weil man weiß ja nicht, was ernst gemeint ist und was nicht. Ironie funktioniert nicht, wenn man tot ist. Regel Nummer eins. Ne, das stimmt schon auch. Ironie gehört den Lebenden. Ironie gehört den Lebenden. Leben, leben, wir sind die Lebenden. Amen. Ja, einatmen, ausatmen. Ja, ich weiß nicht, es ist schwierig. Es gibt ja hier, bei L'Oreal wird ja immer auf den Grabsteinen diese Quietsche-Ente gesetzt. Das finde ich wiederum ganz niedlich. L'Oreal setzt als Hologramm Quietsche-Entchen auf andere Gräber. Ich dachte, so L'Oreal-Fans machen das. L'Oreal-Fans setzen Quietsche-Entchen auf das Grab von L'Oreal. Ja. Krass. Und das ist ganz süss so, das ist ganz nett. Das wird immer gereinigt dann, also das ist dann glaube ich auch Grabschändung, aber ich weiß nicht. Ja, ja. Weil die müssen ja auch, ich weiß nicht, die räumen ja irgendwann weg und dann kommen neue hin und dann. Aber das ist schon, das ist ganz nett, aber du hast schon recht, man muss da wirklich aufpassen, weil man weiss ja auch nicht, was passiert. Hast du Angst zu sterben? Geht. Hattest du mal so eine Nahtoderfahrung, wo man sagt, oh jetzt lebe ich mein Leben anders, so klischeehaft, jetzt lebe ich mein Leben anders, weil es könnte ja jeder Tag der Letzte sein. Ich bin mal auf dem Berg geklettert und hatte wirklich Angst, dass ich nie mehr runterkomme. Das hast du mir mal erzählt. Das war wirklich sehr furchteinflössend. Aber da dachte ich dann eher so, was mache ich jetzt, rufe ich da einen Hubschrauber an oder was oder wie passiert das? Wie ruft man einen Hubschrauber an? Ganz, ganz schwierig. Hast du Empfang gehabt denn? Ich weiß nicht. Ich glaube ein bisschen, ich glaube ein bisschen. Aber ich war in einem anderen Land und dann sagst du ja Buenos Dias, si no comprendo Helicoptero. Si, no comprendo nada. Pardon? No hablo espanol. No, no, no, mi sono al mando. Y sono el Cap capitano tres muchos
arrivandos. El capitano?
No.
Ay, ay, ay, el capitano.
Buenos noches.
Bip.
Dann lieber sterben.
Ich würde, glaube ich, lieber sterben,
als jemand eine Nummer anzurufen,
wo ich weiss, dass da jemand mit einer Sprache drangeht,
die ich nicht spreche.
Ehrlich gesagt, lieber auf dem Berg verrotten. Das wäre aber einfach mal für so eine Gameshow. Ruf wirklich, keine Ahnung, ruf in der Mongolei an und du musst irgendwas erreichen. Also du musst irgendwie, keine Ahnung, du musst ... Die Person zum Weinen bringen. Oder du musst erfragen, was gerade der Goldkurs ist oder sowas. Und du musst es irgendwie hinkriegen, ohne die Sprache zu beherrschen. Weil die Mongolen so viel Gold haben, oder was? Klar. Das ganze Genghis Khan-Gold, da spricht keiner drüber. Alle Nazi-Gold, Nazi-Gold. Ich glaube, Genghis Khan wäre echt, wo wir gerade bei Toten sind, der wäre echt sauer, was mit seinem Land, also der hat es ja übergeben als Weltmacht und jetzt ist die Mongolei das Land, wo man fragt, wo liegt die Mongolei eigentlich, wo ist die eigentlich, ist auch ein riesiges Land. Wenn man nicht weiss, wo ein Land ist, dann ist das Land auch nichts. Es ist eine sehr eurozentrische Sichtweise in der Tat, aber also jedes Land, wo ich nicht weiss, wo es ist, ist es auch nicht wert zu wissen, wo es ist. Muss man auch mal sagen. Ich habe lange dieses Quiz gemacht auf dem Handy, wo man dann sich auch beibringen konnte, wie die ganzen afrikanischen Länder heissen, wo die sind. Das ist auch echt schwierig. Das ist vor allem schwierig, weil es so viele sind. Ich habe mich dafür interessiert. Ich wollte einmal wissen, wenn mir jemand auf Afrika zeigt,
wollte ich sagen, das ist das und das Land.
Das ist der Chart.
Idee, Vereinigte Staaten von Afrika.
Ein grosses Land.
Ja.
Nenenenenen Afrika, nenenenenen Afrika. Mit jedem Land.
Asien, Mongolei.
Das kannst du überall spielen, dieses Musical.
Es funktioniert einfach. Australien nene, Mongolei. Das kannst du überall spielen, hast du dieses Musical. Es funktioniert einfach.
Nene, nene, Australien.
Ja, ist ein Hit.
Es ist wirklich ein Hit.
Und falls ihr vielleicht in Köln Musical-Fans seid,
kommt doch vorbei West Side Story,
vielleicht sitzen wir vor euch.
Weil wir die ganze Zeit, ja, weil wir die ganze Zeit
die ersten Reihe geblockt haben.
Wir singen jedes Lied.
Leonard Bernstein hat es geschrieben.
Bernstein, Bernstein, Bernstein. Ist auch immer so eine Frage, diese deutschen Namen im Englischen, die man dann wieder Deutsch ausspricht. Leonard Bernstein hat es geschrieben. Ja, du kannst ja nicht Bernstein sagen, obwohl der Name wahrscheinlich ursprünglich so hieß, seine Familie kommt, vielleicht hat er aus Deutschland, ich meine, es gibt ja keine originär amerikanischen Familien, aber dann ist er auch, wie jetzt mit diesem Trump-Ding, mit diesem Müller-Report, wo man dann, wo man dann der jetzt irgendwie groß ausnahm, wo man als Deutscher immer so fragt, wir wissen es, wir wissen es besser. Naja, es ist ja schon klar, dass der in Amerika nicht Müller heißt und dass da irgendwann die Übung direkt war. Ich sag, knallert Müller-Report, die wissen noch, Müller-Bericht, die wissen es doch nicht besser. Jeder tut sich schwer, irgendwie, Horst Kleber, wie heißt der, Clemens Kleber, sitzt dann da und sagt dann ja der Müller und dann muss er dann so, weil du dann irgendwie, also entweder du sagst es falsch oder du versuchst es richtig zu sagen und musst dann irgendwie nochmal drei Umwege machen. Das ist dann der Müller-Report. Niemand kann es richtig sagen. Und dann fragt man sich, kann man nicht einfach Müller sagen oder ist es dann wieder, oh ihr Deutschen checkt es nicht. Weil es ist ja ursprünglich ein deutscher Name. Warum kann man denn dann nicht den deutschen Begriff sagen? Ja, vor allem weil der Director of Photography von Louis heißt Paul Köstner. Also Köstner einfach. Auch mit Ö? Nee, mit O-E. Ah ja, okay. Und dann habe ich mal einen Podcast mit ihm gehört. Und er bricht sich einen ab bei dem Namen. Und sein Gegenüber bricht sich einem ab. Und es ist immer so ein Köstner, Köstner. Und dann war irgendwann die Frage, komm, wie heißt er eigentlich? Er sagt, ja, ich habe es mal gehört. Ich war mal in München, da hat man mir gesagt, dass es einfach Köstner ist. Aber komm, alle die alten Generationen sagen Kaus, Köstner. Und man denkt auch irgendwann, Leute, wollen wir das denn einfach sagen? Und bei Mueller denke ich mir auch. Alle brechen sich immer einen ab bei dem Namen. Wir wissen es besser, es ist der Müller-Report. Ja, es ist der Müller-Bericht. Der Müller-Bericht. Müller-Bericht. So, jetzt mal auf den Tisch.
Jetzt haben wir den Müller-Bericht mal am Tisch.
Prost.
Es ist schwierig, weil man will natürlich auch deren Kultur ehren und sagen, okay, man kann es ja als Deutsch sprechen.
Mioje. Aber irgendwie sowas, oder auch sowas, wo ich mir dachte, also jetzt sowas wie Jake Gyllenhaal, wo ja man auch das Gyllenhaal einamerikanisch
ausspricht, der kommt ja glaube ich aus Schweden
oder so, dann ist es irgendwie oder
Hillenhaale,
wo man dann auch sagt, oder Scarlett Johansson
oder Johansson, auch immer,
ja, Scarlett Johansson,
wo man dann auch mal fragt,
ist man der komplette Depp, wenn man
so ausspricht?
Will, da, Johansson, die Rielenhaale. Den Film. Nenenenen, Rielenhaal, nenenen, Rielenhaal. Aber ich finde nicht, weil ich finde, wenn man einem Land wirklich selbstbewusst gegenübertreten sollte, das ist Amerika. Das ist das einzige Land, die einem Scheiss,
die einen Fuck darauf geben.
Ich war nicht bei Starbucks, wir wären bei Starbucks.
Wenn man sagt, ich heisse Stefan,
sagen die, das ist denen scheissegal.
Es ist trotzdem Steven oder Stefan oder Stefan,
Stefan,
es ist immer anders.
Und denen ist es scheissegal, die geben sich keine Mühe,
sich anzupassen oder so.
Also du sagst einfach Kulturkampf, man sagt ab jetzt Müllerbericht. Das ist aber auch, wenn man sagt Alejandro oder so, aber ich heiße Alejandro, da sagen die trotzdem Alejandro. Die geben sich ja keine Mühe bei dem Namen. Ja, vor allem es gibt dann so manche Sachen, die haben in Deutschland auch einen anderen Namen. Du sagst ja auch London und nicht London. Und es gibt eine deutsche Bezeichnung dafür.
Warum ist es denn bei manchen Sachen so und bei manchen
nicht? Wobei ich behaupte,
auch in Deutschland sagst du primär
den Namen, wie auch
in dem Land die Stadt genannt wird.
Wohingegen Munich,
Cologne, Berlin.
Ja. Nee, aber Munich und
Cologne sind einfach neue Titel. Colonia sagst du auch. Im Spanischen sagen die zu Köln Colonia. Und dann sagt man auch, wir sagen doch auch nicht Madrenheim, sondern Madrid. Ja, es ist total schwer, weil einerseits will man natürlich die fremde Kultur irgendwie respektieren, auf der anderen Seite will man es sich auch nicht komplett lächerlich machen, wie zum Beispiel mit dieser, ich glaube, wirtamesischen Nudelsuppe, die momentan total in ist, die geschrieben wird, p-h-o, die man aber irgendwie pho oder sowas ausspricht. Ich hätte mittlerweile, es ist einfach ein Ausatmen. Pho, pho, ist auch ein Gericht. Ja, guten Tag, will hier, genau, ja die gleiche Adresse. Genau, wir hätten zweimal die große Salami und vier und dreimal die Pfaff mit Tofu bitte einfach zum Liefer. Ja, ja, die Augen so leicht schliessend, sinnlich, so Bett. Aber auf der anderen Seite, man sagt ja auch nicht Pizza, man sagt ja Pizza. Ich glaube, Pfau. Da kann man nicht einfach Pfau sagen als deutsche Bezeichnung für ein nicht deutsches Gericht. Das ist ja in Ordnung. Ich mag ich glaube ich ganz gern. Also alle Zutaten, die da drin sind, mag ich gern. Das ist der einzige Grund, warum ich es noch nicht bestellt habe. Nudeln und Wasser, wow. Da hast du jetzt immer richtig auf den Fenster gelegt, Stefan. Ich sage nur, Nudeln und Wasser, tip top. Wasser trinke ich wahnsinnig gern, hält an deinem Leben, ist gesund, kaum Kalorien, ich würde sagen unter einer Kalorie.
Die Leitvariante, ja.
Kalorie dann auch.
Und Nudeln sind immer machbar.
Nudeln mit Pesto, Nudeln mit Wasser, ist alles.
Gebackene Nudeln.
Gebackene Nudeln, gebratene Nudeln, alles gut.
Eiernudeln, Bandnudeln.
Was es nicht gibt, ist sowas wie gestampfte Nudeln.
Also wenn wir uns mal an der Kartoffel
orientieren, ja, Kartoffeln kannst du braten,
kannst du frittieren, wunderbar.
Nudeln wird nie gestampft.
Oder gibt es da bestimmt, ist
Gnocchi nicht gestampft? Ne, das ist irgendwas mit Kartoffeln,
glaube ich. Oh, Spätze?
Sind Spätze nicht gestampfte,
gestampfte und
gespresste Nudeln? Kartoffeln
eher. Nudeln sind ja keine Kartoffeln, jetzt so klassische Barster. Wenn du das stampfst, gibt es da irgendwas? Schau mal nach. Dann kommt vielleicht das nächste Woche. Ravioli vielleicht. Kommt an, wie glatt du stampfst. Frittierte Nudeln gibt es auch nicht so oft. Das braucht man ja auch nicht, weil da ist ja schon Teig drin. Aber Cannelloni sind frittierte Nudeln, oder? Ich Ich weiß nicht. So eine grosse Nudel, wo Sachen drin sind und dann frittiert. Ist das nicht eine Cannelloni? Ich weiß nicht, ob es dann frittiert ist nochmal. Oder ob man sagt. Gebacken? Es reicht. Gebacken? Gebacken vielleicht. Ist gebacken nicht frittiert? Ey, tatsächlich, ich war gestern kurz davor, und da danke ich dir, du hast einen guten Einfluss auf mein Leben, weil du mir als Negativbeispiel dienst, weil ich tatsächlich gestern vor dem vielleicht epochalsten Fehlkauf aller Zeiten stand, ihn nicht getätigt habe. Und zwar habe ich im Moment so ein bisschen Mangel an Küchengeräten. Und ich denke immer so, ein Selbstminker wäre gut. Wie im Moment? Wie im Moment? Ich bin eingezogen in meine Wohnung und ich hatte so einen Junggesellen-Spirit.
Ich brauche einen Löffel, eine Gabel, mehr braucht sie nicht. Ich brauche keinen Dosenöffner, ich habe Mama.
Und irgendwann wird man dann aber sesshaft und irgendwann verliert man dann diesen Junggesellen-Charme und denkt sich, ist einfach nur erbärmlich.
Und dann kommt so dieser Wunsch nach Küchengeräten und du denkst dir, ein Mixer wäre schon geil.
Immer so, ich mache mir manchmal Bananenmilch und dann stampfst du dir halt mit deiner Gabel echten Wolf und dann denkst du dir, ich lebe nicht mehr um 18 Jahre. Das Leben ist zu kurz. Das Leben ist zu kurz, um mit der Gabel zu stampfen. Und dann denkst du dir, okay, irgendwas muss her. Aber ich bin zu faul, um irgendwie ein Elektro-Warngerät zu labeln. Deswegen bin ich immer beim Supermarkt. Und beim Supermarkt gibt es manchmal ja auch solche Sachen, wie ein Toaster, Sandmaker, Waffel.
Ganz schlecht. Ich weiß, ja, support your local,
was auch immer, aber ich bin der
schlechteste Konsument. Support your local Saturn.
Das ist, glaube ich. Ja.
Ich glaube, ich bin der schlechteste
Konsument, den es gibt.
Und deswegen gucke ich immer beim Supermarkt.
Und letztens hatte ich so ein geiles
Video gesehen von einem Tomaten-Sandwich.
Und es ist super simpel. Es ist ein getoasteter Toast, und Freunde, schreibt auf, getoasteter Toast, schöner Strich Mayonnaise, Tomaten, Salz, Pfeffer, Toast, fertig. Wie, Mayonnaise und dann einfach geschnittene Tomaten drauf? Einfach geschnittene Tomaten drauf, Salz, Pfeffer, fertig. Und ich bin ja generell Purist.
Ich denke ja, je weniger Zutaten, desto besser.
Und deswegen eigentlich nur Tomate.
Und eine Tomate ist ja schon geil an sich.
Ist viel dran.
Mayonnaise, glaube ich, unterstützt das gut.
Da dachte ich mir, eigentlich ein Toaster wäre super.
Und dann stehe ich beim Supermarkt und gucke halt so in diese ganzen Ecken, wo nichts, was man essen kann, ist,
was so ein bisschen diese dunklen, schattigen Ecken
des Supermarkts sind, Ductape, irgendwie so komische Türstopper. Duct Tales. Duct Tales Comics. Und dann aber auch so ein Bereich, wo es Küchengeräte gibt. Aber ich dachte mir, jetzt bin ich am Ziel, jetzt hole ich mir endlich meinen Toaster, ich gehe da hin. Und der einzige Toaster, den sie hatten, Sandwich-Megger, war ein Merchandise Fan-Toaster vom. FC Köln. 1. FC Köln! Und dann schluck ich mir dieses Ding ein und denk mir, okay, pro ist es ein Toaster, kontra... Stand das auch, und das machen manche Fan-Toaster, das Logo des 1. FC Köln in der Toast. Ich sag mal so, ja, es war ein solcher Stanz-Toaster, aber nicht das Logo des 1. FC Köln, sondern... Geisbock? Nein, drittes? Dom? Richtig, den Kölner Dom. Der Kölner Dom, also in dieser Ansicht, sehr schmal, sehr hochkant, also maximal ungeeignet, nur von der Frontsicht, maximal ungeeignet für einen Toast, wo wirklich vielleicht irgendwie so 20 Prozent des Toasts überhaupt getoastet wird. Ja, ja, das ist scheiße. Und damit du das Motiv siehst, muss es russschwarz reingetoastet werden, ist momentan eh eine schwere Phase, um Kathedralen zu toasten. Ja, eben. Deswegen, da ohnehin schon mal kritisch. Notre Dame wurde im Real Life getoastet. Das ist auch nicht. Aber das stimmt. Meine Theorie war immer, der grösste Fan, der grösste Fußballfan hat diesen Toaster, weil er sogar das Toasterlebnis an sich aufgibt für ein schlechteres Toasterlebnis für seinen Verein. Hauptsache, er hat die BVB, die BVB-Kreis auf seinem Toast scheiß drauf, wenn der Rest nicht getoastet ist.
Hauptsache, den Verein unterstützen.
Da stand drauf, dieser Toast hatte zwei Features.
Erstens, toastet ausschließlich in der Form des Kölner Doms.
Zweitens, wenn der Toast fertig ist, gibt es keinen Kling, sondern dann wird die Hymne des 1. FC Köln gespielt.
Nnennennennen, FC Köln. Nnennennen, noch ein Tor. Und ich stand wirklich vor diesem Toaster und dachte mir, Naja, keine Ahnung. Kölle a la. Hat nicht jeder Verein so eine Hymne? Aber singt ein Toaster aus vollem Hals oder ist es so ein Chor? Wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Ist es so eine Männerstimme, die kommt? Ich weiß es nicht. Ist das so ein Chor, der aus so einem schlechten Lautsprecher dröhnt? Ich denke, das wird wie bei so diesen Audio-Grußkarten sein, dass halt irgendein billiger Audiochip. Aber warum nimmt man da nicht einen Menschen, der so peinlich berührt, auch weil er alleine ist?öhle aller Fall. Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß auch nicht genau, was der Töne wird.
Ich stand wirklich vor diesem Toaster und dachte mir,
so dringend kannst du keinen Toaster brauchen.
Das kann nicht sein.
Das ist das schlechteste Objekt,
was sie jemals von Menschenhand kreiert.
Wenn ich so wenige Ansprüche wie du an Küchengeräte
hätte, hätte ich mir die gekauft.
Ich hatte kaum Ansprüche. Mein einziger Anspruch war, dass es ein Toaster ist. Dass wenn du wirklich dieses Objekt verpfändest, dass der Pfandmeister da drauf schreibt, Objekt Toaster. Das reicht schon. Es muss in die Kategorie fallen. Bei Wohnungsauflösungen muss es unter der Liste Haushaltsgeräte auflösen. Und nicht unter Sonstiges. Nicht Sonstiges, genau. Das ist das einzige Kriterium. Nicht Sonstiges. Das fand ich so lustig bei Mozart in der Wohnung. Da war ich in Wien und dann haben die da so ein Modell gehabt von der Wohnung auch. Und dann haben die, war die voll gerümpelt mit so kleinen Miniaturstühlen und Tischen. Ich dachte mir, das sah so aus wie so ein Kind, was sich so eine Playmobil-Ritterburg gekauft hat und dann aber zu oft sich zu Weihnachten das Expansion-Pack gekauft hat. Oder vom grossen Bruder noch die Playmobil-Möbel vererbt hat und dann da einfach reingehaut hat. Sie ein bisschen zu oft das Expansion-Pack gekauft hat, wo man auch irgendwann sagt, jetzt ist Piratenchiff angesagt, weg von der Ritterburg. So sah es ein bisschen aus und dann kam irgendwann der Audio-Guide dann auch zu dem Punkt und hat gesagt, nee, das liegt daran, die haben den Nachlass gefunden bei der Wohnungsauflösung von Mozart. und da standen so viele Möbel drauf und wir haben versucht die aufzuteilen, weil das waren so viele Möbel, unsagbar viele Möbel für diesen Raum, den es ja eigentlich zur Verfügung gab, weil das war keine grosse Wohnung und dann haben die versucht, das aufzustellen und deswegen, also wahrscheinlich sah einfach aus wie zu viele Experten-Packs. Oder beim Nachlass hat einfach jemand sich verrechnet. Man konnte damals noch nicht so gut rechnen. Aber die Möbel waren damals viel kleiner als heute. Und auch viele sonstige Punkte, viele, wo man nicht weiß, es ist ein Stuhl, es ist ein Sekretär, man weiß es nicht genau. Aber das fand ich sehr lustig. Aber das stimmt, der Toaster sollte auf jeden Fall unser Toaster fallen. Es soll die Kategorie fallen, aber ich dachte mir, ich habe die Tomaten schon eingepackt, ich habe Miracle-Vip-Light schon im Korb. Nee, ich lege es nochmal zurück. Ach, schade. Und das ist der Walk of Shame, vor allem wenn man Gemüse nochmal zurücklegt. Ja, wenn du irgendwie so eine Fünferpack Snickers legst, legst du zurück und dann neben dir der andere nickt sie zu und sagt, gute Entscheidung. Hang in there, du brauchst keine fünf plus eins Snickers heute Abend.
Aber wenn du Gemüse zurücklegst, dann gucken dich Leute an mit, was ist da passiert? Ähm, ich bin mittlerweile stolz darauf, ich bin so weit, dass man nicht mehr, also wenn ich in die Stadt muss, um einzukaufen für einen Kuchen zum Beispiel, man erkennt nicht mehr in meinem Einkauf zwangsläufig, was ich mache. Ah, das ist ja ein guter Schritt. Früher war immer, ich hatte weder Kuchenbackform noch diesen Rühr-Ding, was so reinhält.
Rührstrup, Rührstab. Ja, es ist mehr als ein Stab. Ja, aber es ist glaube ich Rührstab. Also ich hatte diesen Rührer neu kaufen, ich musste eine Schüssel neu kaufen, ich musste die ganzen Zutaten kaufen, dann die Kuchenform neu kaufen. Ich sag mal so, ich war ein offenes Kuch. In der Stadt wussten Leute, was ich vorhabe. Darauf habe ich keine Lust mehr. Du warst ein Rezept auf dem Fließband. Ich war wirklich genau so. Man hätte ein Foto machen können, und man hätte es nachkochen können. Zwei Eier, ein Messbecher, Mehl. Man musste auch die Form, die danach rauskommen, wusste man. Man musste alles. Das hat mir nicht gefallen. Und deswegen mittlerweile habe ich so viele Sachen dann doch angesammelt über die letzten fünf Jahre hier, dass ich zumindest einen Bestand habe, einen Repertoire habe, wo man danach nicht mehr erkennt, was ich mache. Ich kaufe Eier und Mehl und Leute wissen, Leute rätseln. Leute wissen nicht, es könnte alles sein. Es könnte Pasta sein, es könnte auch ein Kuchen sein, wir wissen es nicht. Das finde ich ganz gut. Das ist ein klassischer Einkauf, also Hemd, Krawatte und Bügelbrett und Bügeleisen,
einfach so dieses klassische Bewerbungsrische. Das Startup-Hack, aber zum ersten Mal jetzt auch. Genau. Und das war es bei dem Kuchen auch. Es war unangenehm, eine Kuchenform zu kaufen, diesen Rührstab, diese Schüssel, wo man das macht. Ja. Du hast nicht mal Mehl zu Hause, du hast nicht mal Backpulver zu Hause.
Was hast du zu Hause?
Alles neu kaufen.
Aber das ist halt wirklich auch so,
ich glaube, der Kauf
hätte mir auch bevorgestanden, wenn ich einen Sandwichmaker gefunden hätte.
Dann hast du einen Sandwichmaker,
Toast, Käse,
Schinken, irgendeinen
Cocktail-Dip und so und die Kassiererin
weiss einfach, wird ein guter Abend heute, oder?
20 Scheiben Toast?
Nee, ich fange jetzt an im Toast-Business. Das ist Starterpack. Heute ist mein erster Tag. Ich bin auch der grösste Fan von Starterpacks, dem Begriff Starterpacks. Oft geht es darüber nicht hinaus bei mir, oft bleibe ich beim Starterpack hängen. Oft reicht einem das Starterpack ja auch. Mir gefällt nur dieses Wort einer Tür in neue Welt. Ja. So, jetzt bin ich, es ist so... Also du hast den Ball, den Handschuh und den Schläger. Ja. Und du denkst dir, soll ich noch die drei Extra-Bälle dazukaufen? Lieber schon. Lieber schon, man weiß nicht. Starter-Pack und Extra-Bälle. Ich kenn mich, lieber die Extra-Bälle noch. Ja, ich kenn mich gut genug. Beatball, Starter-Pack, diese beiden Holzschläger und ein Ball. Lieber noch zwei neue Bälle. Ja, das stimmt schon. Im praktischen Bälle Starterpack. Das ist so befriedend. Starterpack sind wirklich herrlich. Ich glaube, für mich wäre auch diese Seite was. Es gibt ja diese Seite, wo du nicht Klamotten einfach nur kaufen kannst, die du suchen musst, sondern du kriegst ja Outfit-Startup-Bags. Genial. Und es gibt ja so, also ich hab das total, dass ich sage, wenn ich etwas sehe oder auch einen Laden betrete, hier würde der und der einkaufen. Hier würde XY einkaufen, hier würde der junge sportliche Kumpel einkaufen, hier würde der, sagen wir mal ein bisschen versnobbte BWL-Kumpel einkaufen.
Man hat, ich teile Läden ein in Menschen und ihre Kleidungsstile
und so. Und ich finde,
bei dieser
Kleidungsfirma kann man sich ja dann Startup-Packs
kaufen. So das BWL
Student-Startup-Pack.
Du kannst auch schnell zum neuen Menschen
werden, das gefällt mir daran. Vollidiot-Startup-Pack.
Ja, das finde ich eine gute Idee. Werbung. Hey Leute, seid ihr auf der Suche nach einem tollen Podcast? Dann weiß ich auch nicht, was wir euch empfehlen können. Na Stefan, doch, klar. Was denn? Nie gehört, der fantastische Podcast von unserer Kollegin Katjana Gerz. Das habe ich doch nie gehört. Pfff, wow. Ja, das stimmt, Katjana hat einen fantastischen Podcast an den Start gebracht. Nie gehört, der Podcast, der dir eine Stimme gibt. Er präsentiert mir das Ganze von Gelo Revoice, die Haltestabletten, die ihr kennt. Die habe ich übrigens damals immer genommen. Kleiner Fun-Fate tatsächlich wirklich bei Bandauftritten und als ich meine Musical-Aufführung habe ich Gelo Revoice geschluckt. Wirklich? Ja. Aber warum sind es denn Tabletten, wenn die Gelo heißen? Ich stelle mir dir immer so ein Gel vor. Die werden auch so ein bisschen schleimig, schmecken so ein bisschen nach Kirsch, werden ein bisschen schleimig und stellen dann irgendwie die Schleimhaut wieder her. Für mich macht das voll Sinn alles. Ich akzeptiere auch diesen leichten schleimigen Geschmack, weil es einfach, weil es dir die Schleimhäute wieder herstellt. Das ergibt alles Sinn. Aber was ist, wenn es dir gut geht und du sie trotzdem nimmst, wird dann deine Stimme besser? Lass uns weiter über den Podcast sprechen. Katharina hat viele Gäste zu Gast. Ja, Donny O'Sullivan zum Beispiel gerade erst gehabt. Aber es geht vor allem darum, Leuten eine Stimme zu geben, die keine haben. Haha, das ist ja der clevere Marketing-Gag. Da Warm-Upper sind da, Lach-Yoga-Trainer sind da, Poetry-Slammer und halt viele mehr. Es sind nicht so viele Poetry-Slammer, das kommt jetzt ein bisschen komisch rüber. Es hält sich in Grenzen. Ja, ihr könnt es überall abonnieren, wo es Podcasts gibt, selbstverständlich, auf podstars.de slash stimme oder abonniert uns einfach über iTunes, Spotify, etc. Wie läuft es mit deiner Freundessuche? Es haben sich einige gemeldet, tatsächlich. Ja, ich bin auch immer. Bei mir haben sich sogar Leute gemeldet, ich weiß nicht warum, mir schicken oft mir Leute Mails, um sie an dich weiterzuleiten, als wärst du irgendwie so ein König, den man nicht persönlich ansprechen darf. Oder als wäre ich einfach nur sehr schwer zu finden, als wäre so eine persönliche Person oder ein Grater. Ey, mir schreiben auch oft Leute, ey Florentin, sag mal Stefan, dass er mir antworten soll. Ich schreib immer zurück, wenn er dir nicht antwortet, hat er einen Grund, dir nicht zu antworten. Ja, ich kriege aber auch von dir häufig. Also für dich, Florentin ant. Echt? Sag mal, Florentin, ich soll dir übrigens ausrichten, dass du bei Twitter mal wieder mehr machen sollst. Ach so, okay. Ist schon ein bisschen älter. Kann man mir auch direkt schreiten. Aber okay. Genau, also, noch mal, es ist ein Comedy-Podcast, ich habe viele, sehr, sehr viele, wirklich ernste Nachrichten bekommen. Ja. Freundschafts, also viele haben sich beworben um meine Freundschaft. Solche paar, ich weiß nicht, ob es ein bisschen indiskret ist, weil die sind wirklich sehr privat, teilweise. Auch häufig fangen die an mit, mir geht es auch so schlecht heute. Also so soll es nicht rüberkommen. Ich habe ein bisschen Angst gehabt, ich habe ein bisschen Angst um meine Reputation nach den ganzen Nachrichten. Aber man sieht, es gibt einen Markt für Freunde. Aber meinst du, die wollen einfach nur irgendeinen Freund oder die wollen speziell mit dir befreundet sein? Die wollen schon speziell mit mir befreundet sein. Ich bin schon ein ziemlich cooler Typ. Leonie schreibt zum Beispiel, weird, durch den wöchentlichen Podcast habe ich das Gefühl, richtig gut mit dir befreundet zu sein. Name von der Redaktion geendet? Name von der Redaktion, naja, die Schreibweise hätte ich jetzt im Kopf geändert. Leonie mit IE am Ende. XY schreibt, Stefan, mir ist so angekommen, dass du neue Freunde brauchst, die meine Bewerbung. Ich habe keine Zeit, Motivation für regelmässige Unternehmungen und mir ist egal, wenn du dich zwei Monate nicht meldest. Das ist doch das Schöne an Freundschaften. Wenn man sich trifft, ist schön, wenn nicht auch. Ich bin selten lustig, meistens gemein, aber kann mit sehr guter, lauter Rockmusik hören. Bin bereit für ein Date. Sowas finde ich nicht schlecht eigentlich. Das ist eigentlich die perfekte Freundschaft. Oft gemein. Hat da jemand mal Feedback gegeben? Du, pass mal auf, XY. Du bist echt oft gemein einfach. Uli hat auch geschrieben, sie, eine sehr nette Nachricht. Also viele Leute wollen offensichtlich, sind bereit, eine Freundschaft mit mir zu suchen.
Und ich glaube, es ist ja auch so ein bisschen diese digitale Zeit, Alter, wo man die ganze Zeit oberflächliche Instagram-Freundschaften pflegt.
Text, Chat, Emoji.
Ja, und es ist, glaube ich, es geht weg von richtigen Freundschaften.
Und war jemand dabei? Hast du jemanden gefunden, wo du sagst, ja?
Ich glaube, ich muss mal wieder mit den echten Menschen aus meinem Leben,
mit den Jungs mal wieder einen trinken gehen,
mal wieder ins Stadion.
Nee, auf jeden Fall war einiges dabei.
Vielleicht mal gucken, vielleicht treffe ich mich
ja mal mit den Leuten. Ja, schreib mal.
Schreib mal.
Es ist sofort sexuell, sorry.
Ja, ich kann es total verstehen.
Und das ist auch genau das Problem,
worauf ich letzte Woche anspielen wollte. Das ist ja das Problem bei Freundschaften. Also Freundschaften funktionieren ähnlich wie Dates. Die sexuelle Komponente fehlt halt nur. Nur leider ist es besetzt, zu fragen, was ist deine Handynummer? Oder wollen wir uns mal wiedersehen? Ach so. Das sind besetzte Begriffe. Ja. Sexuell besetzte Begriffe. Und deswegen ist es noch schwieriger, Freundschaften zu schließen. Und es kommt oft auch ein bisschen komisch rüber, wenn man spitz das unbedingt nochmal betont, dass es nur freundschaftlich ist. Wenn du sagst, kann ich ja nur machen, aber nur freundschaftlich. Das ist rein freundschaftlich. Weil ich glaube, da werden Leute eher skeptisch, die sagen, warum betonst du das? Aber ich würde mich wirklich gerne wiedersehen. Ja, aber ich glaube, man vermutet eher das Gegenteil, dass es irgendwie so eine Strategie ist, so eine Pick-up-Strategie, so, werd erst mal ihr Freund und dann so. Ja, ja, genau. Und dann sagst du so, nee, nee, aber nur freundschaftlich. Und ich glaube, bei vielen geht ja die Alarmglocke an und sagen, nee, nee, nee, nee, mein Lieber. Das Problem bei Pick-up-Artists ist mittlerweile auch, dass alle Pick-up-Artists schon kennen, also dass alle wissen, davon maschen. Ich glaube, irgendwann ... Ach so. Es gab mal so eine elitäre Gruppe, wo das ein Thing war und wo diese Strategien auch ein Thing waren. Ich glaube, mittlerweile kennen doch alle Geschlechter und ist ja auch mittlerweile quasi genderneutral so ein bisschen. Also, es gibt ja auch für Frauen Pickup-Strategien und so. Das ist ja auch nicht mehr nur rein, wo das damals herkam, so ein rein männliches Ding. Und mittlerweile, wir wissen doch alle von allen Strategien so gefühlt. Naja, aber das ist ja nicht notwendigerweise so, dass du was verbergen willst. Also wenn jetzt jemand, eine Frau auf die zukommt und du merkst, oh, die benutzt gerade irgendwelche Strategien, denkst du dann, nee, dann nicht? Oder denkst du dir, ja, ist das dann schlimm? Nee, ich sag nur das was ist noch der sinn davon wenn alle wenn alle die karten schon mal gesehen haben die im spiel eingesetzt werden lohnt es sich das spiel noch zu spielen wenn ich sowohl vom ass weiß als auch vom joker also vom könig bis zur bis zu zwei, habe ich alle Karten schon mal gesehen.
Warum spielen wir das Spiel noch?
Zu dir zu Mau Mau, ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Aber, was auch
als Feedback gut kam, sehr gutes
Feedback für den Tinder-Spruch.
Und tatsächlich hat mir auch jemand geschrieben,
der hat gesagt, der benutzt den schon regelmäßig,
wir haben den Tinder-Anmachspruch aus
Master of None angesprochen.
Also viel Lob an Aziz Ansari. Grosses Lob an Aziz Ansari und für seine Dating-Künste. Aber also der Dating-Spruch ist im Grunde so von wegen so, ah, ich bin gerade auf dem Weg zum Supermarkt, kann ich dir was mitbringen? Und jemand hat geschrieben, ja, ich benutze ihn schon seit Jahren und er hat geschrieben, er benutzt immer ich bin gerade auf dem Weg zum Bäcker, kann ich dir was mitbringen? Weil im Original ist es Whole Foods, was schwer zu übersetzen ist im Deutschen, aber er schreibt Bäcker und er hat geschrieben, garantiert eine Antwort. Boah, der Blick, den du gegeben hast, Leute. Na, ich dachte mir so, wenn du bei einem Spruch garantiert eine Antwort hast, liegt es nicht am Spruch. Nee. Dann bist du einfach ein toller Typ, mein Lieber. Vielleicht sieht er auch er sah gut aus einfach. Er sah umwerfend aus. Ja, guck. Umwerfend. Du hast dich aber auch geantwortet. Also er hatte so ein Anime-Profilbild, deswegen ist es ein bisschen schwierig. Aber umwerfend ist Anime-Profilbild. Das war Umwerfen, wo ich dachte, wow, Shinichi, du bist einfach der schönste Mann. Aber also viele Leute mit Anime-Profilbildern. Falls ihr Probleme habt auf Tinder und nicht wisst, was ihr schreibt, schreibt einfach, hey, ich bin gerade auf dem Weg zum Bäcker, soll ich dir was mitbringen? Und dann können die Leute entweder sagen, oh, du hörst auch das Podcast UFO, oder oh, du schaust auch Masse offen an, oder oh, du bist dieser Typ, der Podcast UFO geschrieben hat. Also verschiedene Möglichkeiten. Verschiedene Möglichkeiten. Es wird sehr schnell sehr Metaperspektiv. Ja genau, auch dann ist es schwierig, das Gespräch zu decherfrieren und auch schwierig danach zu einer normalen Basis, zu einem normalen Gespräch überzugehen. Ja, auf jeden Fall vielen Dank für die tollen Nachrichten und war auf jeden Fall letzte Woche eine lustige Folge, um mal zu checken, wie der Markt, der Freundschaftsmarkt zu aussieht. Wie der Freundschaftsmarkt und der Tindermarkt. Viele sind ja schon vergeben, viele haben ja schon Freunde, muss man tatsächlich sagen, es gibt ja nur noch wenige, die verfügbar sind. Ich hatte lange Zeit auch mal in meinem Freundeskreis das Gefühl, alle haben gerade den falschen Partner. Alle müssten mal ganz kurz irgendwie aufstehen, zwei Plätze nach rechts und sich wieder hinsetzen. Oft zu dieser Eifersuchtsspiele auch, dann ist der eine mit dem anderen zusammen. Dann sitzen wieder alle nebeneinander. Nee, noch mal kurz. Wenn die Männer kurz ausstehen könnten und drei Plätze. Aber tatsächlich gab es in meiner Jugend eine Situation, in der, glaube ich, wirklich, es gab in unserem Freundeskreis, glaube ich, vier Paare und drei Paare waren Eifersuchtspaare, wo einer oder die oder der gesagt hat, ich bin jetzt mit dem zusammen, nur um den eifersüchtig zu machen. Wo ich mir dachte, Leute, Leute, Leute, so funktioniert es nicht, das ist zu kompliziert irgendwann. Kommt mal kurz alle zusammen. Kommt mal irgendwie, du magst doch den Bernd. Und Thomas, du magst doch die Pepito. Das funktioniert doch sonst nicht. Und alle, weil dann bist du eifersüchtig und sagst, Pepito ist doch nur wegen dir aus Thailand hergekommen. Wer hat ihren Pass? Wer hat Pepitos Pass? Wer ist mit ihr in der Scheinehe verheiratet? Das ist doch Bullshit.
Aber ich bin nur in der Scheinehe, um Carmen eifersüchtig zu machen. Carmen wurde abgeschoben. Carmen ist tot. Komm drüber weg, seit drei Jahren. Aber jetzt bin ich mit Pepito, was soll ich jetzt machen? Es ist zu kompliziert, Freunde, es ist einfach zu kompliziert. Und dann das Problem ist, wenn zwei sich, zwei aneinander verliebt sind und der eine ist in einer Eifersuchtsbeziehung und die andere ist auch in einer Eifersuchtsbeziehung, dann können die ja wieder nicht, weil sie in Beziehungen sind und es ist einfach viel komplizierter, als es sein muss, als es war. Aber wollten die beide sich eifersüchtig machen, die auch zusammen waren? Ja, es gab eine solche Verbindung, aber es war so ein bisschen wie so ein Kreisverkehr, dass jeder den Kreisverkehr mochte, aber dann ist auch egal, dann können sie auch genau so gut so bleiben,
weil anders wird es auch nicht funktionieren. Ja, und ich glaube,
das ist wahre Liebe, sich irgendjemanden
zu suchen, um jemand anderen
eifersüchtig zu machen und dann nach einem Jahr zu merken,
du bist eigentlich auch ganz nett. Was ich oft höre,
ist einfach, dass man so lange zusammenbleibt,
bis der Sohn aus dem Haus ist oder die
Tochter.
Das sind jetzt
noch nicht die Sechsklass-Themen, die da eine Rolle gespielt haben. Nee, ich bin gerade zwei Jahre in die Zukunft gesprungen. Tatsächlich habe ich häufig gehört jetzt, dass man sagt, von vielen Klassenkameraden sind die Eltern auseinandergegangen, als der Sohn die Tochter zum Studieren weggezogen ist. Weil, und dann hat man gemerkt, okay, die sind einfach hängen geblieben aufeinander, wegen Kind oder Kindern. Ich habe jetzt in dein Freundschaftsbuch geschrieben und ich fand es auch toll, dass du den Jonas für mich verprügelt hast, als er mich mit Sand beworfen hat. Und ich mag dich echt, aber ich glaube, langfristig wird das nichts mit uns. Lass uns noch den ersten Sohn nach Hause schieben, wenn er auf der Uni ist, aber dann will ich nichts mit dir zu tun haben.
Ich bin weg in dem Moment, wo der aus dem Haus ist. Das ist schon eine harte Ansage. Dann gehe ich nicht mehr mit dir. Die gute alte sechste Klasse. Ah, es war herrlich. Viel Warhammer Fantasy, viel Pen-and-Paper-Rollenspiel
und viel Beziehungen
von außen beobachten, die man nicht versteht
und sich denkt, meine Würfel
lügen nicht.
Liebe Leute, heute müssen wir da ein bisschen
Ehrschluss machen. Stefan muss, Stefan ist so
besiegt. Nein, stimmt ja gar nicht. Wirklich, seit er in Cann
gewesen ist, dann ist er immer so dieses
na und wo warst du, als ich in Cannes war, immer dieser neue Stefan-Lock. Ich habe mich dreimal erst gefragt. Wo warst du, als ich in Cannes war? Ich stand im Supermarkt und habe mich dagegen entschieden in Toaster und da war ich echt stolz auf mich, dass ich ohne Toaster nach Hause gegangen bin. Das kann man nicht einfach entscheiden, das ist gut, da hast du dich über deinen Instinkt, deinen niederen FC Köln-Instinkt hinterher weggesetzt. Ich habe so viele Steckdosen in meiner Wohnung und ich gucke es jede davon an und denke mir, ja, das ist ein Sieg. Da könnt ihr jetzt irgendeinen Scheiss stecken, den ich nicht brauche. Und so ist es leer. Leere Steckdosen sind ein Sieg. Deswegen habe ich einen Trick und habe sehr viele Mehrfachsteckdosen in Kette geschaltet, wirklich durch die ganze Wohnung verlegt. Und eigentlich benutze ich nur eine Steckdose. Das ist richtig clever. Das ist richtig clever. Und mit diesem Lifehack sagen wir goodbye. So eine Empfehlung? Album, Serie, Film? Ich empfehle mal die durchwachsende Serie, aber doch die Prämisse ist nee, naja. Wenn ihr Lust habt auf eine durchwachsende, mittelmässige Serie. Bei der ich aber unfassbar viel Spaß hatte trotzdem, ist Huge in France. Oh ja! Huge in France. Ich fand die teilweise ein bisschen gut, aber teilweise grandios. Also wirklich, das Gefälle der Serie ist mir sehr hoch, aber so fantastische. Wer Curb mag, wird Huge in France, glaube ich, sehr lieben. Wer Curb liebt, wird Big in France ganz okay finden. Huge in France ist eine geile Serie über einen echten Comedian, der wirklich in Frankreich riesig ist und jetzt seine ersten Gehversuche in Amerika wagt, um unter anderem mit seinem Sohn zu connecten. Die Vorstellung, dass man das hier mal mit einem Jan Böhmermann oder so macht, finde ich nach wie vor sehr lustig. Ja. Youth in Germany. Ich finde das echt eine tolle Prämisse. Und teilweise super gut gelayerte Gags,
teilweise einfach dann langweilige, schon ein paar Mal gesehene Tropen,
Zitcom-Tropen, die braucht man noch nicht, aber trotzdem Serienempfehlung von mir. Wunderbar, damit eine schöne Woche von mir den tollen Film Paddington auf Netflix. Paddington! Fantastisch, Krebsdrama. Paddington! Paddington! Ich empfehle Paddington, Paddington Bear. Ich empfehle Pudding, vor allem Vanille und Schokolade im Wirbel. Bis nächste Woche. Macht's gut.
Ja, und vielen Dank an Iruka für das Intro. Ciao!
Ciao!